brad when your bomb mentioned that
there's potential for characters to show
up down the road in
the mcu perhaps maybe in like multiverse
of madness or something where there's
rumors flying around right now any any
chance we do see her later on
in the mcu maybe
that is stuff that's going on probably
above and beyond us
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
have
less than two weeks until marvel's what
if
their very first animated series comes
out on disney plus
and if you don't think that this show is
going to be very
important to the marvel cinematic
universe i have news for you it
is going to be it's going to be
extremely important and this has been
confirmed
by marvel and it does seem like a lot is
about to be set up
like peggy carter moving from the what
if animated series into
the live action marvel cinematic
universe and i had the opportunity to
interview
the head writer ac bradley and the
director
brian andrews and talk to them a little
bit about what if and ask them some
questions like
if we could see peggy carter in
multiverse of madness
i also attended the press conference
where i asked a question as well and
many other questions were asked about
the multiverse
so i'll be breaking all of that down in
this video and be talking about how
important what if is actually going to
be in the mcu
and if you love marvel and all things
pop culture be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos
so let's first start off by talking
about how important this show is
actually going to be to the multiverse
and this was
actually addressed in the press
conference the host brandon davis from
comicbook.com
said look i find it to be no coincidence
that what if is arriving just as the
mcu was diving into a multiverse story
of it all
can you talk about what kind of taste of
the future this might be giving us
as we are still in the beginning phases
of the post infinity saga
of the mcu and this is what brad
winterbomb
executive producer had to say in
response well
yeah i mean it's no coincidence that
this show picks up
right after loki you know the spoiler at
the end of loki and i am about to talk
about the finale so spoiler warning she
says the multiverse has now
erupted in every possible direction and
what if gives us a chance to explore
that and i think you can tell
that in this next saga the multiverse is
gonna be
crucial then if you combine that with
what the writer ac bradley had to say in
an interview with ign
we pretty much get full confirmation
that what if is
canon to the mcu to the mcu's multiverse
she confirmed this in the interview by
saying the multiverse is here
it's real and it's absolutely fantastic
people
what if is just a part of the multiverse
and some of these stories could bleed
into the main
sacred timeline our timeline that loki
introduced and i personally asked ac
bradley if seeing captain carter show up
down the road in the mcu
say in multiverse of madness is a
possibility and this is what her
and director brian andrews had to say i
would give anything to write peggy
carter again hopefully we'll get to see
her more in the show but
that's up to powers greater than me
well i think you absolutely showed that
because
like i said just get started off with
her it's a great start her kicking butt
it's pretty cool to watch on screen and
i really wish we could have
seen that or we can see that live action
uh you know this morning during the
press conference uh brad
winterbomb mentioned that there's
potential for characters to show up down
the road in
the mcu perhaps maybe in like multiverse
of madness or something where there's
rumors flying around right now any any
chance we do see her later on
in the mcu maybe uh
that is stuff that's going on probably
above and beyond us
we all would love that you know as soon
as that's the k i mean we're just like
anyone else
who doesn't even work at marvel it's
like there's there's stuff that we don't
know
uh right because kevin's the lord
overseer and he's got like stuff going
on that
we might be unaware of but it would be
amazing uh
i think both ac and i would love to see
some
you know haley atwell in that suit live
action kicking ass
being amazing we'd all love that yeah so
even though of course they can't tell us
yes this person is going to be in this
live-action
marvel project they do seem very hopeful
they both said that they hope it happens
and they'd love to see it happen
and apparently i'm not the only person
asking this question because in the
press conference somebody else
asked i just watched loki and were
waiting for spider-man and doctor
strange movies and it's not just comic
fans now but every mcu fan knows about
the multiverse can we expect some of
these events of
what if to be a part of the mcu movies
as well
in which executive producer brad
winterbomb responded by saying
yeah i mean i think that without going
into great detail i can tell you that
what if as a project as a story that
exists
in the mcu as you know as important as
any other it's woven into that same
tapestry
these fun little threads there's gonna
be a lot of potential there
and specifically in regards to captain
carter it does really seem like she's
very important
to marvel or at least the writers of
what if and i asked ac bradley
why captain carter is such a driving
force to what if and could be such a
driving force to the mcu in the future
i love peggy carter i've loved her since
her first moment
in the first avenger from agent carter
to and beyond
i think the reason i fell so hard for
peggy carter and then writing captain
carter
was in the show we explored the
different sides of all the heroes we
explored the different sides of thor we
explore a different side of tony but
they're already heroes they're already
super powered up they already have all
the toys
peggy what does she have she's a woman
who knows her worth
and then i got to give her some super
powers i got to say
hells yeah let's show let's make the uh
the outside final match the inside let's
see who she is
yeah and that was such an honor and to
top this all off during the press
conference i actually got to personally
ask a question
to jeffrey wright jeffrey of course is
playing the watcher in marvel's what if
and here was my question to him
the watcher was such an amazing
character and he's so important in
marvel in general
is the watcher appearing in the mcu in a
live action
movie or show something that we could
possibly see or something he would want
to do
and this is his response well what if
is very much about the idea that all
things are
possible so you know and then he took a
second and laughed for a little bit and
said
that's a reasonable question and i guess
the answer to it
is well what if now he didn't really
give me a confirmation of course
he can't but he did put a very good
question out there and it's ironic but
it is
what if what if is a part of the
multiverse that is the mcu right now and
if one character can come from one
universe to another there's no reason
that the watcher from this animated
universe can't come into our main mcu
timeline and be the watcher of that
and like he did say anything is possible
now from here i'd just like to talk
about
the show what if my thoughts on it and
answering some questions that i've had a
lot of you ask me that i actually got
answered during the press conference
one question is are these shows going to
connect to each other or are they going
to be
one off and i've seen the first three
episodes and they were all completely
different they did not connect at all
at least not that we know of so far but
brad wonderbomb actually answered this
question
he said it's an anthology there are
standalone
stories and they're really much like the
films they exist on their owns and
they're trying to create stories
that exist on their own terms so if you
were to watch any episode of what if and
that's the only episode you watched you
get a
full experience hopefully with the
character
that lives a rich life and changes
dynamically and is entertaining and
emotionally satisfying
but at the same time during the press
conference a question was asked if we
are going to see
characters like captain carter or
t'challa as star-lord pop
up in other stories beyond their
introductory episodes in the first
season
and what brad wunderbaum had to say was
early on in the development they started
to realize that some
characters had more story arcs than the
others not necessarily
more important but had a strong
relationship with
the watcher who is a big driving force
behind the series
and we realized as we started developing
a second season that captain carter was
gonna be the character we would revisit
so captain carter is going to return in
season
two and hopefully she'll return in a
multiverse of madness as well but we'll
have to wait and see on that
now for the film fans out there and the
actor fans and people who like to know
about the process
i did ask director brian andrews what it
was like to have
all of these famous mcu actors do
voice-overs and this is what he had to
say
yeah no they're very casual you know
they don't have to worry about it except
for sometimes if they're at their
in their in their in their in their
closet yeah they're very casual but
sometimes we get them to come into
like a particular studio or vietnam or
whatever there's some
you know once things start to open up a
little bit people can get back into a
a venue and record out in there so they
had to look you know
a little bit more normal but they
wouldn't have hours of makeup to be a
hero you know what i mean it's
it's still like sure i'm gonna roll in
and do some voices so i mean
some some of them had some experience in
that regards before maybe some others
didn't
but i think um they all just enjoyed it
it's still it's still their craft
um and i did my best to paint the
picture for them you know if we couldn't
we didn't
i would have loved to have more actors
like at the same time
so they could feed off each other and
get that real energy but they all did
fantastic without and then in some cases
we would either read with them or i just
give them as much
contact you know i'd direct them as best
i could like whatever context they
needed
um you know to to give
to get out of them what we needed for
the show you know so
and they all did amazingly well and i
think they enjoyed it you know they had
a blast you know
during the press conference they
actually specifically talked about
chadwick boseman they talked about how
he actually treated this
kind of like it was theater and every
single person had something
incredible to say about chadwick about
working with chadwick even though
some of them only worked with him for a
short period of time but they all had
amazing things to say about him and doll
talked about how much of a true
professional he was and that he was
actually one of the first people to sign
on to do
what if even though he was battling a
very
very bad cancer at the time and i'll
leave you with my thoughts that say his
episode is one of the better episodes
granted i've only seen three
i super enjoyed the t'challa as
star-lord episode and i think it's a
pretty big reflection of how people
actually saw
chadwick in real life i think a lot of
people are really going to enjoy what if
it's very different in a very refreshing
way and just to see what one little tiny
event can change
is very interesting and i think a lot of
us are going to have a lot of fun
watching these series and like i said
not much longer left to go under two
weeks now i will be doing my live
watch parties for the what if series
with my buddy chris over
at cosmic culture so be sure to go over
to him subscribe and check him out let
me know your thoughts
about this video in the comments down
below don't forget to like it and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you